[Music]
stranger
[Music]
that's a wonderful zip you did good good
morning everybody uh i'm you know as you
can hear i'm still sick but i tested
negative for kovid two times now twice
the wife
very little symptoms positive what and i
sleep with her
well and other things
but the point is uh i don't you know
before we move into anything we have a
by the way an interview with larry elder
today
which i will let you know is actually
from the archive and i don't know why we
never aired it ah it was never aired a
few months ago i think what just
happened is we had something else
sometimes it was maybe more topical we
had to pre-tape him because he was in a
in pacific time is that called satan's
time zone yes and you will get to watch
it and see how the exact same attacks
are being used today and how he was the
exact same person then when they're
trying to say that now he's doing this
for political theater you'll watch it
you'll be like oh no larry elder's the
same guy no same dude but the point is
with the cop well let me say hello to
everyone first hello gerald a hi how are
you feeling better are you i'm i mean no
i you said your wife might have the
kovid well i we're not sure uh-huh
uh-huh she did so it was inconclusive
and they say to treat that as
presumptive positive and go get a pcr
test oh yeah very nice and i'll get into
treating it as a potential positive
quarter black you're good yo what's up
i'm going we're getting better no rona
not anymore no no sickle cell no
no
blade microbes all washed out and uh
dave landau who by the way is going to
be uh this saturday in beaverton
michigan and uh boy how are you good i
don't know what i've never been to
beaverton but i would imagine that the
audience looks something like
something like this
oh no i thought i had a no
it was supposed to be beavers it was
supposed to be people it was going to be
this is a horrible thing but here's the
thing i will say
about a ton of beavers
so many beers we didn't get it on the
screen well i i sent them they were
adorable well well i'm sure that by the
time we were done photoshopping it they
wouldn't be so adorable yeah
that's true be crazed be personal come
out to beaverton and i have a few
questions for you today we're going to
be taking your chat after larry elder
but you think they're going to be some
pipes bursting tonight in california oh
man yeah why whatever some fortification
happening i don't know you guys comment
below let me know before so do this
again before
you actually get the results afterwards
uh your point is moot
[Applause]
do i test a negative two times okay
and the lady uh who's doing the testing
using the term loosely she says uh
she says well you know you tested
negative twice and one was the rep and
one was a more accurate i don't know
what they are yeah she said but because
your wife has it i would just treat it
as a potential positive [ __ ] so you know
play it safe don't go to she said self
quarantine don't see your you know stay
away from your kids for 10 days don't go
to work for two weeks and i go ah you're
a liberal see because you don't
understand that these are life-altering
changes yeah just don't just remain just
don't imp don't be employable for two
weeks don't see your newborn children
for 10 days like this is just we're all
in this together no we're not
yeah
i think it's good just to treat every
disease that could exist yeah instead of
just something you might have it just
makes common sense i treat polio when i
have a cough yes
i just go the whole nine yards a chair
like what's wrong it might be a sinus
infection could be polio every time it
rains and i get that little i get that
little crick in my knee i limp and i
said i'll be a huckleberry
people say what are you doing i said i
don't know tb could have been eradicated
maybe i'm shooting in the air
so we're going to be talking about
california we're going to be talking
about some new coveted tests uh
i should say covet studies studies okay
um which are very interesting and we're
going to be talking about the um the the
gala of the polar the met gala right
yeah
tax the rich the gala of this 30 g's a
plate the common man's yes eventually
yeah absolutely but hey stephen it's for
charity though it's for charity oh yeah
well then so was hamilton hey
you know can we take one of the most uh
one of the most interesting uh
historical figures right in american
history yeah make them gay and rap
sounds like the kids want it'll sell out
um okay but before we get to that
leftist teachers on tick-tock and this
has been something that this is also the
reason that we show this to you guys is
because people do have echo chambers
yeah and i think it's important that you
see when people say well people have
gone extreme right people have gone
extreme left that you see the difference
between this is considered not only
extreme right but pen shapiro this show
we're the nazis so this is as far
extreme right as you get and i want to
show you
what has been going viral and passes
for moderate
left on tick tock where you know the the
chai comes are spying on us
gaining our faces along with our blocks
okay along with our blackhawks from the
taliban mm-hmm we got black hawk from
taliban and we destroy the school with
uh tick tock
we're playing chess you playing checkers
you're so stupid it's a 3d
it's 3d
look look the screen is slow more angle
to see you
so
leftist teachers on tick tock have a new
theory
the thing is if i describe it i'm going
to be accused of racism because it is
it is racist but what they are
presupposing
is that teaching children to behave
is racist but don't take my word for it
i made a comment on one of miss april's
recently talked about pbis in which i
stated
with the hug and a lot of y'all wanted
to know more about that so here we go
first of all thank you to jack koppa who
reminded me that um dina simmons was the
first to coin this term so thank you
jack so much so if pbis concerns itself
with positive behaviors um we have to
ask ourselves okay well what are those
positive behaviors and it's things like
making sure that you're following
directions and making sure that you're
sitting quietly and you are in your seat
and all these things that come from
white culture oh [ __ ] the idea of just
sitting quiet and being told stuff and
taking things in in a passive stance is
not a thing that's in with many cultures
so if we're positively enforcing these
behaviors
elements of white culture which
therefore keeps whiteness at the center
which is the definition of white
supremacy you can't say that first off
this this oh man this
same sex attracted david i don't know
the proper term uh shouldn't ever say
the word whiteness without accompanying
it with this
i don't think i've seen any this is just
another way of saying that black people
yell out at movies it really is it's
pretty could have burned your jiffy
pockets
and by the way if whiteness is at the
center it is not supremacy supremacy is
on top you [ __ ] you teacher everything
else is below if it's just a part of
everything else it's not supremacy well
yeah
with that about the next time the kid's
unruly you treat him like big mama and
just beat the [ __ ] out of him
go get a switch kick y'all switch off
the trees
you ever seen a kid reach for like a
candy bar at a grocery store and you're
like oh man this is gonna
hurt but i'm gonna watch
here's the thing here's the thing though
uh as well um
i don't entirely disagree we've talked
about this in the sense that young boys
it's not a race thing and this is what
happens right this is how they try and
conflate race and gender so i've talked
about this in the past when i used to
say look i don't think that same-sex
marriage is the same as heterosexual
marriage doesn't mean that i don't want
kids to be in a household i'd rather
than be in a household in the system but
i think the ideal is with a mother and a
father and they would say well that's
well that's the same argument people
used against interracial marriage i said
that's a complete red herring why i
don't believe that
a white mother can provide something
that a black mother couldn't i believe
that a mother can provide something that
a man can't i believe that men and women
are intrinsically different in men and
women and boys and girls learn
differently that's true it's not black
and white it's young boys don't
typically learn sitting and taking notes
that's why they score lower throughout
all of their formative years right grade
school hi junior high high school and
then blow girls out of the water and the
sats when they can study on their own
time and using their own methods
so it's important to know yeah i think
why don't let's find some common ground
there reform the way we educate young
boys yeah or be racist you're gonna let
kids run roughshod over the school
though like sitting there and being
quiet okay so they just get to run
around with i've seen those videos yeah
does does that sound like learning to
you
i don't know pretty interesting i saw
the substitutes with uh what's tom
behringer
if i throw one of these kids out of the
water how many do we have left i saw the
substitute two and three with treat
williams really yeah yeah
god didn't say joe be polite
well it really is it's a different movie
yeah there's that uh what what is it 187
where they're all doing russian roulette
at the end of the movie i have no idea
yes you do let's move on to more white
supremacy
i have a criticism of this next person
who happens to have
more melanin in the skin as nick cannon
refers to it so and a wig oh ooh
is that true quarterback it's definitely
a wig he married him oh i have no idea
100 that's a weird see i'm going to deal
with that former gay tick tock whiteness
i don't know how to identify weaves does
nick cannon still have bigfoot tattooed
on his back i have no idea that is a big
woman he married
sturdy girl mariah carey
um joy reed was really mad uh talking
about nicki minaj from the met gala oh
yeah because nicki minaj and by the way
this is something that they don't really
often talk about the fact that you have
black americans who are actually
probably the demographic that are the
single most vaccine hesitant yeah not
necessarily it's not republicans not
conservatives but black americans
because they're like well you know
syphilis
to try and really sort of coma comb our
entire community for votes the entire
system is oppressed
oppressive and racist so we don't really
trust you now it's like no trust us when
it comes to this vaccine that we put in
your arm they don't however
they let the mask slip a little bit when
joy reid was furious yesterday talking
about nicki minaj at the met gala
because she didn't want to get the
vaccine uh here you go and people like
nicki minaj i have to say this
you have a platform sister that is 22
million followers okay i have two
million followers you have 22 million
followers on twitter for you to use your
platform to encourage our community to
not protect themselves and save their
lives my god sister you could do better
than that you got that platform
it's a blessing it's a blessing that you
got that that people listen to you and
they listen to you more they listen to
me solution how about you both just shut
the hell up
hey
there's more of that around here let's
find some common ground i think i gotta
go with nicki minaj on this though i
think she has the right to use her
platform for how she feels yeah well she
had a friend who she said i'll she said
the balls were swollen yeah it was like
i'm a little nervous
it's 20 21 so you have to ask if the
friend was male
yeah i don't i don't agree that you
shouldn't a friend got elephant balls is
it a male christmas bag what's better
with you you mean a person with balls a
person a person a balling person bowling
person person with a penis guys person
with a penis yeah i mean a man
no no i mean a human man no mickey not
talking about frogs asexual and [ __ ]
this isn't jurassic park chris is a man
he got out nikki
that the the out of touch the out of
touch nature of democrats with the black
community today oh yeah is unbelievable
if you were to pull black the black
community on lgbtq aaip they what
right you pull them they want more
policing 86 want as much policing or
more you pull them on government
mandated vaccines you pull them on
overall trust of government you would
think that it was the january 6th
insurrectionist yeah
what is the poll that you're doing a yes
b no c
how many how do you spell that
how many things you're going to add to
that letters
that's too many letters
and [ __ ]
so uh this this is something that
happened on cnn too we're going to get
to the metcalf because i just think the
met gala is perfect
uh
this morning the ceo of the texas
association of business glenn hammer
look he was on cnn and this is why this
is important you know we always try and
make sure that you guys are uh are aware
of what's going on again in the opposite
sides uh echo chamber yeah cnn and
they're not msnbc they're supposed to be
neutral
this is a moment that we were watching
you were watching this this morning
right now we were watching it live we
said you got to pull this clip where
it's someone who walked out this host
with her dnc talking points
and in no way was prepared for the most
basic
forward statistically accurate response
and then tried to backpedal i don't know
that you have a more perfect example of
how again out of touch uh and out of
sync the left is here you go yeah i just
want to highlight one of your arguments
you say the vaccine is the most
effective way to prevent the
transmission of coven 19. of course
right
um
it's also the way to get the texas
economy back on its feet i mean if you
just go back to the economic how do you
i know mike's rocking and rolling
my question is oh okay my question is
how do you okay
but it
can't let me ask my question glenn you
tell me what how did how does it help
anyone if someone leaves a larger
company goes to a smaller company or
just drops out of the labor force
i mean this is a half-baked proposal no
one's just coming
cafe everyone knows that it was terrible
process is going to be challenged in the
courts and you know i i don't think this
was the this was a terrible process we
want people to get vaccinated the
president should have brought people
together and said he did something
unfortunately that continues to divide
us
we'll see where this conversation goes
no
no the conversation ended she didn't
realize this is the way to get the texas
economy what are you talking about oh oh
oh oh you're in new york yeah yeah you
don't understand or maybe she's in d.c i
have no idea but no it's not california
oh it's not new york don't you underst
just this is when people say for example
if someone argues overpopulation you
should go drive across the country yeah
if they say the economy's been decimated
you say oh drive across the country they
have no idea we talked about this
yesterday with ben shapiro look you can
look at this on a state-by-state basis
states like texas have done well states
like california states like new york
have not she wasn't ready for that no it
hadn't even occurred to her she just
didn't pull basic economic data
she was like what she tried to say
what's the way to optimize
texas's economic future i don't know you
know what i'm going to answer your
question with a question should we do it
like california
yeah how do you think that's going for
you i thought we were going to stay
successful but what do you think we
should do
we're open suggestions yeah please i
feel like she's like haven't you been
watching us tell how scary this is that
you guys are still open have you
considered a tent city yeah
well we got something awesome do you
have a sanctuary do you have overpasses
in texas
huh could you how old can you fit under
there yeah the cartel hangs people from
because our economy's awesome
hey by the way look we're going to move
on to matt gal here uh podcast uh you
can listen to the podcast in case
anyone's oh yeah on trouble on youtube
we're on apple android spotify and the
best way to tune in hit the notification
bell but it's a live show monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern yeah make it a
part of your routine live without a net
do it like chris o'donnell in batman and
robin what when his parents died oh yeah
yeah yeah um
and again my question is what do you
think is going to happen with the
california election so
let's continue with this aoc
do you think jesus i can't help myself
do you think that uh do you think that
the democrats feel the way about aoc
like like that republicans feel
conservatives feel about like the the q
and shaman
or do you think they they really think
that she's rejuvenating their base no
see i i disagree i think that the
democrats want her i don't i think she's
a useful idiot for them right now sure
as long as they get votes eventually
they're going to cast her out but if she
gets too powerful she will eat them yeah
but the cute but the cute on shaman to
us is a useless idiot oh that's true
yeah yeah yeah funny okay i think they
know yeah if she becomes the leader of
heaven's gate they're like sure we gotta
cut it off
have we gone too far
i think she can still stump for me i
don't know i was with you until why why
can't i bring it on the spaceship with
me
what's this weird smell in the comments
yesterday she attended the commons man
gala uh the aoc gala
basically yeah it is that's what we'll
call it yeah the aoc gallery
wearing this truly inspiring dress
my guide tacks the rich oh she can read
aoc
i didn't know you model as well oh my
god damn
i love how she's acting like this is new
like taylor swift winning her 19th award
oh my god
i don't what am i oh it says that i
didn't even know i love how she's acting
like everyone there isn't rich right
yeah isn't it funny guys not really i'm
talking about which by the way is a
little different from her fellow squad
member ilan omar took a different route
and uh made an even bigger splash with
her dress smash the patriarchy uh and
your brother which seems almost like an
admission on the
so to carry on with with dave's point
quick reminder here met gala tickets
actually do go for about thirty thousand
dollars
yes and i know you're saying oh well
hold on a second it's a fundraiser sure
it goes to the museum's costume
institute
i'm just glad that we can get that done
i'm glad we come back
and i say this as a man who owns a
studio where we have an entire backroom
full of really weird costumes but
they're cheap it's not lost on me there
should be no endowment to the arts let
me just say that there should be no look
if you guys want to raise money for
charity sure but here's the thing they
[ __ ] about the church so samaritan's
purse for example who they [ __ ] about
and complain these christian
fundamentalists go into uh liberia when
ebola has a 50 mortality rate right one
of two the only private organization i
believe the only non-government entity
to go in and serve people churches the
american church the most charitable
institution in the history of the world
not just the united states of america
far more charitable than the government
they create soup kitchens they help
members of their church they reach out
to the community these people spend
thirty thousand dollars a ticket
although let's be honest a lot of them
are comped it's the plebes who pay the
30 thousand dollars a ticket to go to
more
hyperly gay tick-tock-esque fashion
it's expensive yeah but they dress
homeless people in peter pan costumes
right
right if the gal is any indication
there'll be more outfits like these this
is what we're talking about oh that's
such a terrible what is this what is
that in the middle what's on the left he
looks sad what the hell
the left was kim kardashian actually
that wasn't everybody
that's what that was kim kardashian yeah
yeah that's cool yeah
yeah that is
that's the the newest fashion in kabul
right now yeah
oh she that was that looks like it was a
mistake like i said green
suit the face open blue man group i
oh my morph
wanted to have a trash can
hey guys is it everything it's black man
group get it is this does this mr mark
it's my dating history oh boy
you ain't black um
back to aoc though and it's a good point
you realize this this is this is a lady
this is a abroad if i may
and i may uh who sells tax the rich
sweatshirts for 58. wow
58. back in uh 2020 she wore a 14 000
outfit for her vogue photo shoot and
saying hi guys who cares i didn't keep
it doesn't matter you're trying to make
people feel what about the self-esteem
issue you're trying to make people feel
lesser than for not having a 14 000
outfit you think that it's harmful to
people's self-esteem you know not having
a bmi over 40 on a magazine what about
putting a 14 000 dress
on a magazine uh by the way illegally
parked her test i don't know if there's
anything more elitist than illegally
parking your tech your tesla behind the
whole foods that's only two blocks down
no that's insane
i can't it'd be like
it'd be like the equivalent to the most
diverse human being ever it's like
that's a single uh a single black mother
amputee from detroit uh who's uh trans
with ricketts you're like well that
checks all the boxes and even something
i don't have here it's like parking your
bentley on a homeless man yes
will you watch this while i go in
do you need us to validate parking no
skid row
i have to get fair trade coffee i'm
sorry you're bleeding yes i have to get
i have to get uh i have to get slave
free chocolate excuse me while i run
over jamie foxx playing a violin i don't
know
i wish i loved stories exaggerated i
wish i loved anything as much as aoc
loves running over homeless men i i
don't think anybody does love anything
that much and she uh she still owes by
the way two thousand dollars in taxes
from 2020 for a failed publishing
company so she does she hasn't look you
can pay those taxes
you suck let the government teat she's
owes taxes yes i thought i thought as
american citizens if we owe taxes they
came for us they came knocking on the
doors the good thing is give her two
grand she spray painted a white dress at
a thirty thousand dollar gala where they
will give it to uh you know other other
costumes which they consider fashion but
um her abuela still doesn't have a roof
so hey oh oh but there was a gofundme
for that i thought we took care of this
issue it wasn't allowed to go i know i'm
just saying yeah i wasn't allowed to go
because she was offended by it i thought
she was shamed into at least paying for
the roof and saying no no boyle i'll
take care of it oh no no no she has no
shame didn't you see the video that was
just yesterday yeah no she must have
fallen asleep
she illegally parked her tesla at a
whole foods two blocks down did you miss
that you heard that right oh i did yeah
well she was gonna go to whole foods
later right oh well i mean it would be
here's the thing what i'm saying is she
perpetuates all the negative stereotypes
she does some whereas the ones on the
right don't really exist certainly not
as far as someone in office it would be
like if i
if i started a house fire by resting my
tiki torch because i had to go pick up
my clan's hood
that would be the right way extremist
version
[Laughter]
of parking your tesla illegally at whole
foods two blocks away
and it wasn't even february
so
it is acceptable in february
it's cold
and here's a way to by the way another
blatant display hypocrisy at the met
gala was here's something to people
understand the elitists only the workers
had to wear masks
only the workers were wearing that so if
a bunch of celebrities out there and
multi i don't know how tens of thousands
of dollars sometimes hundreds of
thousands of dollars in outfits not
wearing masks only the workers serving
them wear masks except for jlo and ben
affleck because they just had to out gay
the fellow tick tock does that work
cringe bro taco flavor
i just think this is look you wonder why
republicans you wonder why donald trump
has picked up the blue dog democrats
it's because people whether you
understand this or not people don't want
to be sermonized to about taxing the
rich and the wealthy from people who are
at an event that looks it look like a
glorified hunger games that's exactly
look exactly that's exactly what it is
it is
wow that's not even a stretch that's
literally what it is it's just well
except it's weirder on the left it is
officially passed like yeah you pass the
hunger games
aoc did try to get out ahead of this
though stephen she did say that you know
i know people are going to say i was at
this event but but celebrities and local
politicians get invited to these things
all the time yeah and they are killing
kids they're just not out yet yeah right
they're doing all of these just in the
back room
[Laughter]
gosh and don't you don't you love too
that the the tax rate keeps changing
like joe biden's like uh when it was
barack obama and every family met when
he was vp every family making uh over
three hundred thousand dollars a year
now he's president yeah on anyone making
over 400 000 a year really but what what
happens at 400 000. well that's my
salary cap
399.
what a dick that's so transparent just
tell us what you want so tax the rich
okay fine take all their money do it
today we've already talked about this it
won't pay for your programs aoc it's
just look and i want you
you guys come and tell me where you
think the tax the top marginal tax rate
should start i just don't believe that
we should create a system based on envy
right people try and say oh greed it's
selfish actually i i don't think that
greed is
a synonym for success
i think that taking someone else's money
that you haven't earned ill-gotten gain
is envy yeah i think that those two are
interchangeable
but greed can also be power which she's
clearly into that yeah yeah oh yeah
that's very true this is we really are
at a point here where um they want to
pit everyone against each other based on
money and then hope that you don't
understand that they are a part of this
elite ruling class yeah well robert
reich is along that same ilk he always
tweets out like i can't believe jeff
bezos makes a hundred and something
thousand dollars per minute and i'm like
i can you shut down the entire economy
and basically we had amazon and that was
it everybody used amazon and they love
it then you quit your job in the 90s
when you see something coming bill put
all your money into something build a
company create something he's allowed to
make the money that he made because he's
the one that took the risk to make that
money i wouldn't be out there building
penis rockets but that's just me right
also i don't i think they need to do it
without subsidies yeah you might prefer
oh i agree but that's that's the whole
difference penis car that's the whole
point ambiguously gay duo penis car
right are we saying
these people don't have a plan
this one's all spoken the fact that they
talk about the top 1 of americans this
is a self-defeating argument let me
explain to you what i mean they are
talking about the rich here in america
because guess who's part of the top one
percent
anywhere else in the globally is the
average american poor americans so the
fact that they are holding americans to
a higher standard of the top one percent
oh so anyone making over 33 000 a year
no no we mean the top one percent of
america oh the country that you hate
which is the only country that has
afforded people the opportunity to be in
the top one percent of the globe and
then we're talking about the top one
percent of america that's the top
0.001 it's almost a coveted mortality
rate
almost yeah 30 no yeah 30 grand is the
line too it's something like 33 000.
someone can bring that up in the control
room i think it's if you're making over
three thousand you're in the top i don't
know if it's ten percent or one percent
globally but this country that is we
have far too much wealth inequality
we're we are lagging behind other
countries you are using the standard
that this country created exclusively
yeah and i know some people point to
some scandinavian countries this is
something we've also talked about
swedish americans have a higher quality
of living and make more money than
swedes in sweden same thing for danish
americans they created what they have
under free market economies and then
migrated towards sort of a hybridized
socialism but the point is if someone
says tax the rich and they mean the rich
in america isn't that nice
for globe for globalist people for
people who want global government the
u.n right they want us to share the same
currency for these people to somehow
well know how a second we're going to
create the dividing lines by american
standards because well you know
significantly higher the same applies to
mortality rates in hospitals the same
applies to quality of care the same
applies to technological innovation we
are greater than a curve
and america is
it's blown past everybody else
historically all right now we can move
on to the covid which is fun hippie
are we talking about you or
i don't i don't we're going
i might have it but i told everyone here
i tested negative twice yeah that's good
enough for me i mean i don't think you
should be kissing dave but nonetheless i
think that's close enough we can't break
the shot she tested negative twice too
i blame the puppets freddie mercury um
mom my wife has it but also my my one of
my relatives i will say yeah her husband
had it yeah and she was looking for an
exemption from the vaccine for something
that i won't get into but she actually
has a medical condition my wife has gbs
and so anyway you guys can sort of make
your own inferences i don't want to give
away too much information yeah but i
heard her on the phone talking about the
exemption with the other person who you
know the other karen on the other end of
the line saying no you can't get an exec
exemption and she said look look look my
husband had it
okay for a week and a half i slept in
the same bed with him
and i screwed him
and didn't get it she didn't say screwed
it's a good point though yeah yeah some
look we don't know why some people have
more of a proclivity toward
horrible symptoms than other people we
know if you're obese that's a that's
obviously a deliberating factor and if
you're older yeah but outside of that
there are some it's rare there are some
younger healthier people who could be
blood type we don't know there's a there
are a lot of doctors like we don't know
why some people have a reaction others
don't yeah tested negative twice my wife
has fewer symptoms tested positive so
isn't that with everything too
when you really think about it yeah some
people get cancer they beat it some
people you know don't if these are fake
if these are false negatives and i'm
actually positive yeah i would describe
this as a moderate cult okay
that's honestly and my wife just had a
fever and she was really she was tired
but that would be great if if you guys
ended up with like a very very low kind
of symptom thing because then you have
the antibodies and you're good to go
well you know my both my parents my
favorite both my parents had it recently
yeah yeah
they're better now though right totally
my dad was fine no matter what i was
worried about my mom because she has
she's had sort of ammonia before and she
has asthma and bronchitis yeah they're
fine
totally fine totally anecdotal totally
anecdotal right used a cocktail of of uh
ivermectin whatever else they had they
then they my dad was already improving
but then went and did the antibody
treatment the monoclonal antibody
treatment which was dismissed as
quackery not that long ago uh or then it
was also dismissed as something that
only the elitists could use it's free in
texas that's insane my parents are dead
let's talk more about your healthy
parents yeah
you're living here but like you said
yesterday that's probably not a bad
thing considering what's going on here
in a minute no no i'm glad they're gone
i am so glad that they're very there's a
world war ii vets oh oh yeah they i
can't imagine the ones that are could
you imagine the greatest generation
putting up with this crap no
you can just see that scene in private
ryan earn this it splashes to the fence
no
no
i was wrong i meant like a longer
longer-lasting light bulb or something
oh we developed leds
you ruined christmas
i was like at the end of saving private
ryan where he's going to the uh cemetery
and you can tell that his like
granddaughters are just bored yeah yeah
they just don't realize that he was
going for realism they were on their
early flip side kicks yeah yeah
stupid granddad fell again somebody oh
my god he's so grounded fought for our
freedom
why are we here right here you don't
know the soldier yeah seriously like war
is like a million years away yeah we're
never gonna have that again for crying
out loud i'm a dude by the way if we
yeah
i'm a man
[Music]
i'm on tick tock i have a lot of
followers grandpa has none
he doesn't have any followers he's so
lame you lose my friend went to the mat
she had a dress that looked like a swan
and sang like that
just sparkle it's 30 grand a plate
pretty cool
yeah
but i couldn't i couldn't wish she could
need because she's a pescatarian
sometimes i cut myself
that's a different story oh yeah it just
makes me feel how sharp is this great
stone
by the way i have never just show we
before we move on to coven talk about
death
this is not i've decided what i'm going
you know you've asked me like what do i
want to do when i die
no we have a plan no but now i have a
different plan no no that's the
difference between the plan that's to
kill me oh okay that's the killing no
but it's if you're going to die if i'm
going to die anyway that's the yeah
in depth yes but then i told my wife
that i don't really she was like do you
want to be cremated do you want to
because in french canada they almost
always do open casket my wife has
they've often been cremated yeah i said
i don't care you know leave me out for
the trash on tuesday didn't really make
a difference to me but now i know
exactly what i want to do because
there's a cemetery that has like
pre-civil war gravestones around here
you know what i'm talking about yeah and
uh i was thinking would be really cool
like what there was this there's a
mausoleum you know in there and i said i
want the biggest mausoleum that we can
get at the cemetery and uh when people
go in i want someone to accurately you
know accurate to scale replicate my body
only a little bit decomposed and make it
like a haunted house so they have a
respect and just
i like it that's a good idea yeah
then they have to go through and like
jump out at them so even in the
afterlife i'll be busting people's balls
make sure the ass is to scale as well
yeah
we'll have to have a counterweight
um
so this is a new study there and by the
way this is a new study that comes on
the heels of two other studies
and to be clear this study involved
thousands thousands of cases that were
reviewed now it's not definitive i just
want to be clear
but it does matter in other words this
may not be entirely definitive that it
doesn't tell you everything yeah then
again neither does cnn so
a new pre-print study published by the
atlantic uh the indication there was
that 50 percent of covet
hospitalizations
may be mild or asymptomatic uh cases so
they looked at 50 000 wow hospital
admissions for covid yeah uh with a va
to be clear now i know what you're
saying because i'll get to that in a
second the va there aren't as many women
uh or children so that's that's the next
step they're gonna allow 14 year olds to
it's going to be a camouflage propeller
cap but
this is something i've talked about i
talked about with remember ben shapiro
uh
i mean years ago really at this point
the start of the pandemic a year and a
half ago i said the number that matters
is death per capita and i repeated it
yesterday we've talked about this the
entire way through why because you can't
well you still can manipulate those
numbers if it's death with cobit but
it's far uh
less prone to manipulation than cases
because right now we don't even really i
mean i just tested negative twice but
they said treat it like a positive yeah
yeah do they list that as a positive
because my wife is positive in the
household to report it i have no idea
how many tests does that count us when
they talk about hospital admissions
we'll get here in a second guess what if
you're admitted to a hospital because
you're getting tested at a hospital
let's say there's no place around you
that has rapid testing the only place at
the hospital you test positive for cobit
that in many instances is a
hospitalization for covid right so this
is important this doesn't give you the
whole picture deaths per capita
gives you a more clear picture provided
we have the criteria that is clear as to
what constitutes a death with kovid as
opposed to from kovid for example the
guy who tried to blow his own head off
with a shotgun uh shouldn't count but he
did the guy who got into a motorcycle
wreck and happened to have kovid
shouldn't count but it did still
there's less foul play with the deaths
per capita so they looked at 50 000
hospital admissions for uh kovid at the
va
and they found that 45
of unvaccinated patients had completely
asymptomatic or very mild symptoms
versus 57 percent of the vaccinated so
either way that's about half had no
symptoms or very mild no this is not in
a very small percentage of those people
actually ended up dying yeah so we need
to be clear about this that means that
half of these hospital admissions when
you're hearing about it
are just people going to have covered oh
okay all right what did i do go home
drink fluid all right yeah because i
think that that's half they only bring
you in if you're sick sick right like
until you like you get a bed in the room
and everything well you would think so
but no not a 50 or asymptomatic or very
mild cases in other words at the va they
were counting these as hospital
admissions because someone was in the
hospital who happened to have covet
why would they admit you if you have no
symptoms yeah it doesn't make sense
you're like hey i'm not feeling well do
i have covert and then versus i feel
great do i've covered right yeah
it doesn't make any sense why are you
there so and this is this is also
important well that's a good point
everything's here's why i think some
people go there right now they're a few
completely unrelated
vaccine mandate in the united states
right 100 100 100 employees or more you
have to force them to be vaccinated or
courtney joe biden according to fauci
he's giving them an offlane it's being
moderate right test them every week at a
cost of the second that was announced
find a test within 50 miles
of your house
we can't like a rapid response i was
texting you yesterday no well no home
test not home and actually none of the
and you know the drive-through tests as
well that they would have a lot of
pharmacies not available here there was
a new emergency care uh not emergency
room urgent care clinic that had some
and that's just because they were new
and nobody knew about them yet remember
i send it to you yeah yeah right down
the block from there was an urgent care
that's been around for a while like it's
a good amount of traffic no test ah
completely unrelated but the reason why
is if your only chance at getting a test
going to a hospital oh you've been
admitted by the way my wife tried
calling that place and they said they
would only give you a test if you had
symptoms meaning like you were you were
sick sick like if you were
you could demonstrate that you were sick
because he's like i have some symptoms
like no but you look fine really
yeah
this is stupid but anything is a symptom
now it's like all right look if you have
a sore throat you don't have a sore
throat you have congested congested
nasal cavity tired headache chills fever
feel cold feel hot stomach distress
irritated bung hole and uh is being a
[ __ ] on there
i said headache
dude i feel like a big [ __ ] do i have
covert uh there's a chance no you're
just canadian positive not saying that
it's not a serious virus i'm just saying
that we are getting a fuller picture of
the numbers so by the way yeah people
will say this doesn't include children
this comes from two other studies that
we wanted to cover on the show but
because of
the rules on youtube we said well you
know it's not rigorous enough until we
have more to add to it so there were two
exclusively pediatric studies to be
clear now i've got the va and it comes
on the heels of two pediatric studies
these were published in may
found that 40 to 45 percent of all
pediatric hospital admissions were cases
where covid was incidental meaning they
were being admitted and you can go to
lotterathr.com right we have the link in
the description you can go read the
sources that means that they were being
admitted for something else like cancer
or a psychiatric episode which by the
way these have increased because of
quarantine isolation people aren't going
to school and they happen to test
positive for covet that's again 40 to 45
percent wow
covet was incidental they didn't even go
because of covet or have symptoms that's
insane everyone gets a covet test if
you're admitted right now in the
hospital are you saying locking kids up
and making them wear masks and scaring
them is somehow hurting them
psychologically no i don't know we
should ask kim kardashian or met gala
outfit don't see a connection
what are you supposed to be uh kim the
american economy
also the
last guy i dated and the guy before him
you got to think that yeah robert
kardashian's just looking up from hell
going
i shouldn't have gotten oj off well
i guess karma is a [ __ ] it's just kind
of it's ironic i got out just in time
yeah
you know i thought it was sad when i
started to get sick but now i'm just
glad you know
count your business instead
[Laughter]
i've met him and i only met him so he
could say bye
[Laughter]
so my family's
[Laughter]
uh the california here we'll go to this
the california recall election today oh
yeah today as is uh as it's known by the
american plumbers association
so
what i don't get the
i'm a little slow i'm sorry a little too
high bro let's go back to joking about
kardashians young people
there's nothing funny
about the kardashians no
or interracial relationships or there's
nothing wrong with that of course
there's nothing wrong with it that's why
there's nothing funny about it i know
that's why i'm not laughing it's
beautiful and brave always
i don't know how to get out of this one
because i'm actually genuine
i don't get out
i don't care who they date no of course
not
i just you know maybe they're crazy
the the young ones you know actually i
got so much flack from the actual i this
is where i found out that white
supremacists were a thing actual
neo-nazis yeah back when they were known
as what they were yeah when i said i
tweeted out maybe years ago i said you
know if my if my daughter brought home
and this is before i had children so if
my daughter brought home uh a black man
from church i'd certainly be happier
than if she brought home a white man
from the dive bar and they're like oh my
gosh i can't believe this cuck and i was
like what what hold on a second oh yeah
no no it's this this is the falling down
i'm nothing like you
yeah and then they tried to they
realized that i wasn't jewish a lot of
white neo-nazis thought i was jewish so
they were saying anti-semitic things i
only realized that i wasn't jewish they
started like photoshopping swastikas on
me to try and say that i hated jews and
then the professor picked that up and
you know and then it got picked up by
professors and they were
attracted and the schools never
reprimanded professors because there's
no accountability for the left and
twitter still let those posts up
photoshop with fake quotes and swastikas
with horribly racist questions
you should have explained to them like
listen no nothing okay there we go you
should have just told them if they were
both in church i would clearly have gone
with the white guy
it's a joke what you get to have a tan
all the time and i got to deal with this
porcelain skin this burning toilet skin
is pretty nice
you gotta admit any racial is the way to
go because you just get your tan all
year well you gotta admit that uh i will
say of and having just had two white
babies
white babies aren't the cutest
no no sadly no like asian babies
like bills bill's little boy half asian
lawyer bill richmond
adorable yeah when i first saw
magnus i went oh
i mean come on he looked like uh he
looked like satan in the crack desert
and passion of the christ in the crowd
i i've never wanted liked babies no no
it's like do you want to hold my kid and
i'm like no i don't want to i don't know
yeah i just don't want to dave i don't
want to hurt it never mind
all right i don't i just think you want
to hold my whole thing can i drop it
then no yeah so um the california recall
is happening today for people who are
what you may be watching this tomorrow
so i don't know this is happening in the
morning it is 10 55 a.m eastern um
and let's give some updates here we have
to be really really really clear very
clear that uh
this is a hard show today it really is
this trend is just
all over all right let me just show the
clip first yeah yesterday some voters
that so that you don't have to take my
word for it take a look it's in the clip
uh el camino real charter high school
real what's spelled real
that should be the you know that like oh
it's not just real you're such an affair
this is america
yeah the school is a car truck he's a
little slow because he had a late night
at the met gala
that was the name of the guy who served
you uh who served you crab cakes on the
tin with a double mask that was
gasping for breath all right it's el
camino real charter high school uh they
were told this is a report from not me
that there were issues with the ballots
people tell us they showed up to vote
this morning in the special california
governor recall election and were told
that computers showed they had already
cast their ballots
what
staffers they say sure apologetic and
helpful but those voters we talked to
are extremely concerned suspicious and
wanting answers
so wait a second they
were told that they already voted
so it's going to be the most secure uh
recall in uh election history yeah yeah
yeah
i'm talking safe and secure just to make
sure that we're all on the same page
yep and secure doo doo doo doo doo doo
break that pipe then get the suitcase
who knows what okay
mushrooms with feet
uh on that same note ashley babbitt
allegedly received
allegedly allegedly allegedly yeah
three ballots at her former address huh
that's weird one for her strange the
photo was tweeted by the twitter account
for ashley uh that raises money by the
way for ashley and her family's legal
fund for people who don't remember
ashley babbitt as a lady who was shot
and uh yeah the only person have to die
on january 6th uh during the
direction yeah or is the capitol police
uh refer to it and the congressional
democrats mighty good shooting
justified that's what they call it yeah
and just to be clear just so i just want
to be very very clear there has never
ever been
any instances recorded of fraud in any
election ever in the history of the
united states of america it has never
happened and so i assume that these
reports that you've seen from multiple
different news outlets and receipts of
course should not be seen with your own
eyes all sources available at
lightweight.com and there is no proof
that there has ever been and no not even
just elections the government is beyond
reproach there's nothing corrupt
people say power corrupts you know what
i think investigative reporting corrupts
how about that that's what i say what
why why are you so busy investigating
other people's business caring about
legitimacy what are you hiding
yeah why are you so nosy yeah
sunshine is poison it's not a
disinfectant what skeleton ballots are
in your closet
the best things happen in the shadows
come on so just kennedy was elected not
by the mafia yes and he was shot by
oswald and of course no bootlegging
so outside of that point
separate issue
janine guerrero am i saying that right
there gerald guerrero
i don't care i think you have to gurgle
last name sounds like a pitcher
eddie's sister on cnn was talking about
of course larry elder is running against
gavin newman holder is a republican
candidate we're going to have an
interview from the archives here in just
a few minutes and it's fascinating to go
back and see what he was saying yeah
just before this he was kind of called
on running
for governor yeah it wasn't a long-term
plan to be really clear
um
janine guerrero
on cnn of course referred to the black
candidate who was pelted with eggs yeah
by a gavin newsome supporter in a
gorilla costume
you would think if you're looking look
white by the way if this were on the
back of a children's menu let's say at
ihop
and it would say like okay would show
you right uh it would show you the
gorilla costume throwing eggs at a black
man
and then it would show you just the
black man and it would ask you to
identify the differences in one of them
is which one's a white supremacist well
cnn would fail the back of the ihop menu
because uh well here you go he has been
able to reach the the minority of voters
in california who embrace his his white
supremacist
world view um and you know he's co-opted
this line by my fellow columnist uh from
from the headline you know calling him
the black face of white supremacy but he
refuses to engage with the actual
substance of our reporting you know the
idea that he his his um views were
shaped by a well-known white supremacist
named jared taylor wait so hold on a
second she just
said
black face
of white supremacy
[Music]
so she's a stupid person yeah i just had
an aneurysm correct
he is the black face of white supremacy
think about that let's what just think
about think about what she just said she
had he he of course what he did these
persons they've infected him and so he
must be a white supremacist even though
he's still black i thought that that was
an oxy i feel that same way every time i
go to costco and i see a bag that says
jumbo shrimp
what like what this is the most
obviously terrible attack to throw at
him because it's the weak idiot it's
idiotic right like it's it's stupid like
calling a black person a white
supremacist
simply because you don't like their
policies like it's worse than what we
saw with uh with ben carson calling him
like an uncle tom and all those
different things that we saw right some
of the representatives in kentucky as
well it's like
what do you what are you saying because
it wasn't enough look this is the only
play that the left has that's a good
point people don't understand this and
we'll go to larry elder and arc so you
will see these attacks were being used
just when he was a talk radio host and a
guy who was gaining an audience people
were listening to him they say uncle tom
right they think that'll work first off
they say black people you vote democrat
and they kind of go with that for a
while right then black people say hey we
think that you're taking us for granted
a little bit and they go anyone who's a
black republican uncle tom and then when
that doesn't work they don't say oh you
know what donald trump got is got a
record number of black people latino
people a surprising number really caught
us off guard outside of six major cities
they don't say hey
maybe they go oh uncle tom isn't uh uh
white supremacist and there's no one in
their entourage to just go um are you
telling are you talking about the guy
next to larry elder
it's just lazy though at this point it
really is because they're like white
supremacists
this guy's black i don't know white
supremacy i guess also that's the only
thing we got i don't know did you see
the the reporting though from the los
angeles times as well they so when we
covered that story about the eggs being
thrown it's like oh larry earl elder cut
short his uh his press or his campaign
event because of unrest and then the
next one was something about the same
thing the headline and it showed larry
elder with his hand on a white woman's
face as though he slapped her
i'm a fan of larry elder but hands off
our white women yeah he played he played
the video and it was like they were
giving each other a hug and welcome
later
i'd be of sound mind to not run this
archive interview with you kind person
of color because you
forget your role don't be going around
slapping white women don't slap any
women but especially white women did you
just look at a white woman cross
let's have a fake tribe you sold your
soul at a crossroads between slapping
white women so you should have slapped
the gorilla mask right off yeah yes to
reveal a white woman yeah and then slap
a white woman yeah she's in both double
slaps
yeah
i would have gotten away with it it
wasn't for you meddling stupid white
[ __ ]
that's it everything that's how they
play duck duck goose just white
supremacist what's your premise white
supremacist all right
it is it's the same they use this
against larry
elder unbelievable this is against ben
carson and by the way if you're watching
right now smash that like button to show
larry elder some of your support right
now because we want him to obviously do
well in california where of course
elections
just i mean there's it's california
secure it's california it's fair the
golden state standard it is yes it is
we'll let you make your own you know
just avoid the piles of human [ __ ] yes
the golden state the smells of the
golden shower
sir you filled this ballad out with your
own species that's not going to scare
you this is a place where you don't have
to disclose
that you have aids when you have sex
with a stranger it actually went up for
a i thought like oh this is one of those
absurd laws like they used to have a
georgia where you can't wear a hat that
scares children on sunday after two
o'clock but only every third sunday like
absurd rules that still exist on the
books no this was relatively recent
people asked the question like hey if i
have an aids infected load should i have
to let somebody know before i have sex
with them no but you need to wear a mask
yeah and you need to have a vaccine
passport yes this is think about that
for a second what a stupid word if
george michael were still alive
he would walk out of the porta potty
after having banged strangers with
reckless abandon and it wouldn't be a
problem unless he didn't have
a neck gator that's true
how big is it how big is his porta potty
how many strangers he probably did have
a turtleneck though yes rolled it up
[Laughter]
that's really good
i'm just saying like you gotta have a
turtleneck so george michael's banging
people in port-a-potties now we have
newsome's uh what's next this is my
question what's next if it doesn't will
they think and you can comment below do
you think that the left will think that
the calling larry elder a white
supremacist worked if gary elder doesn't
win do you think they'll be like oh no
nailed it oh we're high fiving right now
they're like yes that's so good the
black face of white supremacy
i've seen a lot of people post about it
i mean people buy it that's the problem
is like we're laughing at it because
it's absurd but there's plenty of people
that are like yeah he is they're right i
think they stole that though i think i
saw that on the babylon bee like a year
ago like there's no way this will happen
that's where they're pulling all their
places
i can't yeah i can't believe that
anybody would assume that that wouldn't
have happened yeah i'm surprised it
didn't happen this
sooner
i just i you know it's be i don't know
what we do i don't know what we do as a
comedy show anymore
i don't know what we do
when the left is accusing larry elder of
being the black they didn't just say
well he has deeply hidden
self-loathing you know uh tendencies
they said the black face of white
supremacy
i'm not sure where do you go from there
just how about just framing it in a way
that's not [ __ ] i mean if you're
trying to subvert we really are in an
orwellian time where it's double think
and they're they're trying to change
language it's like a second i thought i
thought white supremacy meant that
you hate it you thought white that black
people were inferior like no no it
doesn't mean that but i thought white
supremacy was no no black there were
just as many black people white people
are white supremacists really how many
just the one
well according to the meetings i go to
it's just that we we think we're a
little better oh
you're not in the middle not in the
middle better just more better yeah more
or more equal yes by the way i thought
this was already taken care of with
barack obama and black supremacist louis
veracon and sitting under his teaching
for years just because i thought
uh he said under jeremiah right oh
jeremiah wright who was influenced by
yes also also did all the the the
anti-semitic sorry are you saying i
misnamed the black supremacists you
mixed it up you misnamed the blacksmiths
louis farrakhan blames everything on the
jews
yes and then jeremiah wright is just a
charlatan who humps the podium on stage
uh louis still there is it louis jr now
i i don't know exactly i forget i forgot
about that when i was in times square i
used to always try to grab their
newspaper though and they would not have
it really
not happy about that i'm like oh yeah
i'll take that like
that's not funny i can't read it about
the news not for you
[Laughter]
so now a big part of newsom's strategy
by the way has been uh
appealing to the latino vote that's been
pivotal so this is again look at this
all of it is racially charged from the
left right now you have a black guy
republican who actually wants to improve
the state by the way even joe biden and
elizabeth warren these people who went
down and said hey you got to vote for
gavin newsom elder made a great point he
said you know what they haven't said
they haven't said that gavin newsom has
done a good job because they can't you
know joe biden said you know knew some
as far as i know he was just following
the signs
right that's what he said i was like
that's an endorsement what you're doing
dude that's the best you suck i know
your state's on fire that's okay they
had a maskless dinner at the beginning
of this where everything was actually
named uh after orwellian thing and the
only place where plates are more
expensive than the met gala yes yeah
i've eaten the french laundry or
whatever
oh good for you
scotching cigars afterwards did you i
did did you really what did you know did
you go with newsome i did not
was it a cuckold
with this
with newsom in the entire state of
california so he's been trying to appeal
to latino vote he's probably worried
because 33 of the latino vote went to
donald trump in 2020 that shocked a lot
of people and i expect that to only get
bigger as the left goes further left
again because like i said with black
americans if you actually look at the
individual polling on issues with
latinos they are not expected to be a
democrat voter base now to give you an
idea this is how stupid and out of touch
the left is they were saying that when
mexico made uh they decriminalized
abortion yeah they're saying people from
texas who can't get an abortion they're
going to go down they're going to have
to go down and get it in mexico that's
not how this works
they're simply considering maybe letting
people out of prison who had abortions
and they're simply going to okay maybe
look at some what you would consider far
far right or they would consider
moderate policies you're not going to
get someone from southern california to
go down in the second trimester in
mexico and have them serve an abortion
right up to a gringo this is how out of
touch they are mexican people
mexican-americans typically catholic
very conservative anti-abortion that's
why it was monumental for the law to
even move just an inch and you need to
know what they actually did because
they're not moving the way that you
think they're moving plus a mexican
abortion very different it's just you
stand behind a
kicking donkey yes tijuana is not known
for them okay i'm a doctor just stand
over here yeah i'm a diamond i'm a
doctor and stand right next to the wall
that's taco right here basically
welcome easy design choice
so um wanna drink if you remember by the
way after trump's success even barack
obama said that hispanic evangelicals um
he was the one who
he was the one who sort of acknowledged
at least the first one i know of barack
obama publicly to acknowledge that
hispanic evangelicals
actually helped get such a high
proportion of the latino votes or sorry
latin x next by the way hey go to mexico
call someone latinx see how long it
takes before you get your ass kicked by
a gang of non-gang-related mexicans but
they will form one just for you using
the term latinx but here's barack obama
actually saying this um people were
surprised about
uh a lot of hispanic
folks who voted for trump
but there's a lot of evangelical
hispanics who
you know
the fact that trump
says racist things about mexicans or
puts
uh
detainees uh you know uh uh undocumented
workers in cages
supports their views on
you know gay marriage or abortion so
this is definitely an uphill battle look
for newsome and um i believe we actually
have some exclusive audio of him
robocalls trying to obtain
in california it's happening right now
across california uh the the latinx vote
hola latinx
miamo gavin nussomo los siento de nuevo
por
can we just get another crackhead to
steal some pallets
that's my regular as i go to talk about
order of the blanco supreme blog
if you say it that way it doesn't sound
so bad yeah blanco sabrina if you go and
say can you give me the white
supremacists they go okay i say i'm
sorry ella blanco superimo
there's a woman that tweeted crayola
because it said negro oh i know it's
hilarious there's multiple people it
also said you know they're so dumb why
would you write this on there it's like
do you really think crayola was like
let's slide in the slur i love how
crayola like they replied to and they
were like uh well this is actually
spanish so oh you know that the guy
krill is just waiting yeah because he
can't call that auto reply
just wait until you see the red and
yellow crayons
yeah you're not gonna like them oh boy
racist crayola remember when i was a kid
i was in a carpet box of them this is a
true story i was in a carpool as a kid
and there uh i was i was trying to talk
about uh a black kid in her class i
remember
talking with this this mother at the
carpool thinking uh oh yeah um i'll use
a different name oh yeah andrew um
the
and i stopped i might have been eight or
nine and i thought
i can't say black yeah right i thought
black is offensive and so i said uh the
um
the the the negro kid at school i
thought that was because also keep in
mind that we're half french half english
right so the romance language is like
we're talking about here with crayola
yeah so i stopped myself and she turned
back and said don't you ever say that
black black
[Applause]
of course i just don't know what to say
anymore it's not like you're having
you haven't supper in 1950s montgomery
alabama
and i'll tell you back though that negro
boy yeah yeah top off that men julio
pasta so that [ __ ] uh me and my friend
will be sitting at the lunch counter he
will be sitting wherever you put him he
will be sitting wherever he pleases so
long as it is not
near my aha placemat and of course my
crayolas yes
crayolas for my
oh they've changed this
yeah well that's noir but but again we
separate they so neg was the term for
well negra is a term for black but that
was the term for black people and noah
who was a color so it was two different
words they put it both on
the united states black is the same word
right yeah yeah so they went the other
way where they had a word for black
people they have a word for the black
color and then only relatively recently
do they change so it's it's it's the
point is it's all silly look
if you're not racist who cares that's it
yeah well enjoy your crayolas
fortunately matt damon's just come out
and his daughter has told him that the
n-word is something that he shouldn't
throw all the black yeah oh no he
removes half his catalogue of jokes
the other half is short guy humor that's
how he was trying to tell her that he
wasn't gonna vote for newsome yes
so i preferred
and i'm we're gonna we have to get to
larry elder here we don't have we don't
have a bunch of time but uh before that
speaking of people of color yeah that's
the term we're supposed to use now
yeah black's a shade
anyway
bill cosby um cancelled
what canceled his comedy tour
suddenly he had a comedy tour
that was going to happen i want to make
sure can i get a refund for this i know
you were reversed four dollars on
tickets well yeah so if there was going
to be a comedy tour due to the reversal
of sexual assault him being let loose so
i believe we have a montage of that
first
this was a unwanted three-year vacation
that mr cosby never asked for
but
if mr cosby conviction being overturned
it's for the world and all americans
do you hear that world fairly by the
judicial system that he never asked for
like every one of his victims this is
for all the people who have because i
people of different colors of shame
that's a race color agreed because i i
met them in there these people can't get
lawyers
and so i raped them through
my prisons because i knew they could
have sued me so i said hey you want to
make some toilet rod
this is bill cut he is such
he didn't just rape a few people
um
he raped many small things and by the
way his people said that it was canceled
because uh they didn't want him to say
something that could be used against him
in his unresolved legal matters so yeah
that's the concern turns out the sub of
the people that i raped when i was
inside the slammer actually can't get
some lawyers to give a pro bono and i
didn't know that for all the people
everybody did it in there they were the
king you see what you did
and the good thing is because i was in
california no idea
if this joke is accurate i do not know
where i was between
but i did not have to disclose what i
called the magic johnson disease
so uh to actually though this is this is
everywhere in the news surprising he's
let out
and then he has a tour which was big
right then he cancels the tour and then
the reason for cancelling the tour is
very different so we actually have um
here to help us understand this we're
going to go on the ground to the last
remaining bill cosby apologist
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right okay the last remaining bill
cosby uh apologists we have on the
ground
uh are you there can you hear me sir
what
wait what's up oh hey what's up
hey what's up bud
what are you doing i'm eating pudding
uh well i'm just reporting live on bill
cosby like you've asked well you're in
uh he's what he's supposed to be on the
ground here and does his correspond at
your third chair dave what are you doing
uh why are you wearing a cosby sweater
uh it's not it's a couse fandiniker okay
why are you wearing that that uh well
it's a little chilly in here huh it's a
cosby sweater just to be clear it's a
style that bill cosby might wear sure i
don't like it that's i don't like it at
all
you know i don't care i'm bringing this
style back now that bill cosby has been
found innocent well okay he wasn't let's
be clear about this bill cosby he was
not found he was not found innocent he
was let out on a technicality yeah like
they're just gonna let a convicted
rapist out of prison uh that's exactly
that is exactly what they did
so
he sexually assaulted like
dozens of women yeah allegedly
so hold on i want to make sure that this
i want to make sure we have this right
generally following us you think that
bill cosby is innocent
are any of us truly innocent
yes of rape yes yeah all of us here are
innocent of yeah no one here is
we're all innocent of rape dave all
right okay so maybe if rape is anybody
here uh guilty of raising a generation
hey is anybody here guilty of being
america's dad anybody can we show hands
i mean that's pretty good that's a good
point yeah exactly it's a good point
thank you
bill cosby is a terrible man
terribly funny
okay
i don't know i don't really i'm not very
that i'm not fun understand about what's
what's happening here okay what's that
what's that dave huh this yeah what is
that this this beauty yeah this is my
good luck football
it's uh signed by o.j simpson i think i
know where this is going nope actually
it was signed by mark furman but he did
use oj's blood oh my god
that doesn't even that doesn't even look
like an autograph
it wasn't it was a racial slur but it
smeared over time all right
easy easy on mark fuhrman he watches
fervently all right this has been our on
the ground uh bill cosby last remaining
uh apologist correspondent
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so uh before we have this uh
do we know when this was recorded it was
like was it a few months ago 2015. this
was a while ago this was recorded in
2015 2015 yeah that's what putting on oh
so this one and we never ran this we
never ran it was uh i was actually going
through some of our archives and it was
unlisted like it never got really same
so huh
that was back in uh back in the old days
yeah you know honestly i can't tell you
why uh it didn't end up being released
um we've never actually done that with
with interviews maybe we have now with
other interviews that i didn't even know
what sometimes does happen though if
someone has to pre-tape an interview
yeah and then news breaks and we get a
guest
that's what i assumed it was it was
something you just forget about it yeah
but you said in the studio maybe you
didn't release it because it was
wrongfully accused and in prison
yeah well that could be it or it could
just be that something happened that was
newsworthy right this is the old
michigan studio yeah oh okay wow so this
is back when it used to be in my den and
we were going through the archives they
found us and said you know what you
should probably run this just because
it's very rare that you get to see this
has never been aired before that you get
to see
a glimpse into someone who um
this is how he was treating me back when
he really had nothing to gain from my
show at this point right he didn't need
his very benefit to the show was a very
small show and you can see that he is
exactly the same person and right now
the attack of course is beyond him being
the black face of white supremacy is
that uh he's trying to become another
trump that he's just pandering for votes
well you know what let's go back into
the archives here watch this larry elder
interview and you tell me and then of
course uh the part that we can't show on
youtube is going to be mug club only and
we'll take your chat after you tell me
if he's pandering for votes or if he's
always been the same old larry elder
[Music]
so glad to have this next guest with me
and i know i say that a lot but this is
this is true because
i was raised in a country where we
didn't get am radio we didn't get any
kind of political discourse and it's
funny he can tell me about it i used to
watch his program i had no idea no
background on him but i remember looking
to my dad as a young teenager saying i
think that guy's a conservative or at
the very least a reasonable human being
larryelder.com
he has a book uh dear father dear son
out larry elder thanks for being with us
thank you so much for having me i
appreciate it no i i am so glad to have
you you know it's funny we have a i mean
we have a lot of we have an eclectic mix
of guests right we don't typically just
do the the am radio stuff that everyone
else does we have weird people on
but i i i don't get star struck by
people i have on who are just on cable
news because we didn't have it but your
show i used to what was now was it a
morning or a a daytime show
well i had i had a couple of tv shows
one was called moral court one was
called the larry elder show you're
probably thinking about the larry elder
show that was on for a bit but i've done
radio now for 20 years yes well i know
and i hate to talk about something that
used to but for me that was the only
thing i had access to in canada you're
talking about essentially a government
monopolized media with the cbc in radio
canada and it's it's funny so i just
remember watching as a kid i had no i
didn't know what a republican was you
and john stossel and i sat there and i
said i i just like what these guys have
to say get this barbara walters off
because it came on after t
and i think you were a guest on star
soul if i'm not mistaken i was oh yeah
and also and i are both libertarians
this is true yeah and i think that's why
i was introduced to you because we used
to have tgif sabrina the teenage witch
boy meets world and then 2020 came on
and john stossel would come on with his
sort of smug give me a break you know
this whole segment and and that's where
i saw you and i just said i i had no
idea why i was so drawn to you guys um
you know i i've known stossel for a long
time and people often ask me steven how
i became a libertarian it was kind of a
long process mostly
being exposed to economics but stasso
found some book a magazine called the
reason magazine on on a metro that
somebody had just left and he picked it
up started reading it and it was all
libertarian and that's what got him
interested in interested in
libertarianism so i told him if he'd
missed that bus then he would he would
still be a card-carrying democrat and
apparently he said apparently so well
you know it's funny i actually
subscribed to reason magazine through
one of those guys who sold subscriptions
you know he had the little stick
door-to-door he had been shot in the
face eight times and um
it was i found out i remember i was so
gullible i was young i was like oh what
do you have that's political and i
subscribed to reason magazine and i
remember um i saw him at a cvs
uh or well
it wasn't a cvs it was a different
pharmacy that people won't understand
the name so i'm saying cbcs for
reference and we're seeing him there and
finding out that it was a complete sham
and i was upset but i did have my
reasoned subscription and i read read
that thing religiously for two years um
so it's funny so you say libertarian and
i think that's really interesting this
week because
i feel like you and also have been
incredibly consistent um
socially you lean more liberal i don't
want to misrepresent you so what what is
your point of view then on this supreme
court the decisions last week because i
would imagine for a libertarian it's
much more than the reductive reasoning
of love versus hate
it it is and in california we've had the
issue of same-sex marriage on the ballot
twice and both times i voted in favor of
it and both times my fellow californians
voted against it and i'm okay with that
because i thought that we had a country
where we had the concept of federalism
uh article 1 section 8 of the
constitution outlines the duties and
obligations of the federal government
the 9th and tenth amendment say anything
the federal government can't do
are reserved to the people into the
states and i think marriage and abortion
are issues that should be decided on a
state-by-state basis so while i don't i
don't mind the idea that a state has
accepted same-sex marriage in fact i
voted for it as i said i really disliked
the way it was done ramming it down the
throats of all 50 states when 13 or 14
of them didn't want it same thing they
did with abortion and they were winning
the argument on the ground as they were
with abortion in 1973 when roe v wade
was handed down abortion was available
to 70 percent of the nation's population
similarly same-sex marriage is legal in
about 35-36 states before this and in
the other 14 many of them had something
called civil unions so i don't see any
reason why this had to be shoved down
the throats of the rest of the country
well i will ask you this as someone who
is i'm trying to think uh black
african-american gentleman of color what
should i say here to make sure you don't
call the aclu
well i never use the term
african-american i think it's a stupid
demeaning term that was essentially
rammed down the throats of newspapers by
jesse jackson i'm an american who
happens to be black that's what i call
myself so colored gentlemen we'll go
with that that's okay because all right
i never understand of color yeah
american of color what's funny is
colored is racist people of color is now
correct i can't keep track of the rules
don't give me everything changes when i
when i was a kid it was negro and then
it was afro-american then all of a
sudden african-american and i guess
that's where it is right now if you
notice when newspapers use the term
african-american the next sentence
they'll say black and then i'll go back
there i know they can't cover their
bases
and then it's worse than french-canadian
because you know it's noir is black it's
a color negra is negro
so and then they switch between french
and english you have to be careful with
that because you can use some french
words in english but if you just say
negre people wait what what what did you
just say so you have to be careful and
um again it's just it's funny that this
political correctness people understand
what's politically correct here is
actually offensive in another country
and it's tough to keep but also it's
weird on another level i've seen police
for example describe an assailant as
being quote an african-american how do
you know he wasn't from haiti how do you
know he wasn't from nigeria right you
got a buddy who went up to canada with a
son and his son said dad there aren't
very many uh many black people here in
canada and he said well there are some
so they go driving they go to a a gas
station and the son who's 10 years old
says dad there's an african-american
well how do you know he's from uh
america he's canadian african-american
isn't he right he's haitian canadian
yeah well yeah we have that we have a
huge haitian population funnily enough
in quebec which is a bastion of
multiculturalism and they cr we talked
about these laws a lot they tried to
purify the province pureland it's called
for pure french european blood it's it's
it's horrible it's incredibly racist and
then they had a huge haitian immigration
because i mean they speak french and uh
french canadians are much more racist
than americans so it's funny to see them
flip out now um
so no it's it's funny that you say that
and uh i'm glad to hear that we're not
gonna be stepping on any cultural
landmines um you said that you don't
want to see this given to the courts
because you think people should vote on
it obviously liberals and even some
libertarians say you don't get to fight
fight you don't get to vote on human
rights or civil rights and compare it to
the plight of black americans what do
you say to them
i don't think the comparison is well
taken four members of the supreme court
agree with me that this should be
handled on us on a state-by-state basis
and that sexual orientation is not the
same thing as race
in before 1969 it was illegal for blacks
and whites to marry uh in some parts of
this country mostly in the south uh this
has nothing to do with with races
everything to do with people's behavior
and orientation and i can at least
understand the argument that the
traditional sex traditional proponents
of marriage argue which is that
a marriage is the possibility of having
children or having children and we have
to provide the kinds of role models that
teach men how to be men and women how to
be women again i don't buy that
reasoning but that is at least a
straight face reasoning that a lot of
people feel and the courts ought to have
respected and if you don't like living
in that particular state you can move to
another state if your state is one of
these states that does not support
same-sex marriage you can decide as a
business person you can decide as a
tourist not to go to that state you can
punish that state in that way maybe that
state will then rethink its assumptions
but to cram it down the throats of the
american people by arguing it's the same
thing as the civil rights of the 1950s
as to blacks to me it's unfair and not
well taken and one of the nieces of mlk
is named avida king she's a pastor and
she very much resents the comparison
yeah i can imagine i always talk about
that you know it's tough for me because
obviously i'm not black but i say i if i
were black i'd
again it's something you're born but
you're born black and you're born people
you know people say gay
i've talked about that and i don't want
to i don't want to open that box right
now um i think people don't choose their
sexual desires but everyone has choices
over their sexual actions just like i
have a choice
not saying you you you know you're
watching the love boat and you go hmm
skipper looks great i think i'm gonna go
for him today
right what i am saying is everyone
chooses to act on their sexual actions
so
there is no choice in being black
despite what the left might say i've
seen them say that you're not black
enough so i guess it is a choice on how
you act people people claim i've made a
choice to be white but uh i don't see it
every morning i get up in the mirror and
i go
exactly
like the old cartoon where you jump out
of your skin and then hopefully you can
just jump into a new one like i'm i'm
i'm white now i'm transracial here's my
point actually now we're off on the
rabbit trail the transracial thing i've
talked about this before i want you to
tell me if you think i'm absolutely out
of line here
um
the transgender movement that's where i
think there is a slippery slope the
fundamental interchangeability of
genders with the same-sex marriage i
think it applies you have to apply that
reasoning to transgenderism
transsexualism whatever you want to call
it but i do think it's actually much
more reasonable i'm not saying either is
reasonable
to
change your race than your sex because
think about this for a second just one
second come with me here bruce jenner
had to go through severe hormone
replacement therapy
uh all kinds i mean a surgery where you
essentially amputate your penis and
testicles to become a woman it still
very much looks like a man in a dress
anyone will be able to point it out
rachel dalzahl
slapped on a spray tan and a sideshow
bob
a fake
and fooled the naacp for what a decade i
mean so wouldn't it
seem as you're viewed by the public that
would show you that it's uh it's
obviously a much more physical issue it
looks as if you can uh become somebody
different uh on a racial level easier
than you can become someone different on
a gender level because rachel dolezar
basically said she
felt black yeah so therefore she
is black so you can get up in the
morning and feel amish and become amish
it's fantastic it's yeah it's amazing
you know what's interesting the naacp
gave her more support than they gave
clarence thomas clarence thomas was the
second nominee black nominee for the
supreme court and the naacp did not
support him the uh black magazine called
ebony stephen probably the most widely
circulated black magazine in the country
comes out once a month i know why do you
feel that you think i don't know because
i'm white i know about ebony
to inform your fans who might not be
might not be as knowledgeable as you
stephen
anyway every year they have something
called the 100 plus most influential
black americans and every year they omit
clarence thomas uh thomas soule and
walter william three prominent black
people because they feel that they
aren't black and you ain't black that is
to say they have positions that are
antithetical to the black community but
rachel dolezal good to go explain that
one to me stephen uh i don't think i can
explain it to you i just wanted to make
the joke about her side sideshow bob
perm but you know it's funny the
clarence thomas thing
i was pretty young and when i went back
and and read up on that so i was too
young to fully understand it
right i was going like okay
to the best of my knowledge
it was a joke about like nether region
hair and a cocaine or something i'm
going like this doesn't seem to be a
national story and it just shows you
that some things can get so hyped up in
the moment and when someone comes in
with a fresh point of view and just goes
this is what everyone wasn't up and arms
about i think we're going to have that
about nearly everything occurring these
last few years
i think you're right what happened in
the case of clarence thomas is that one
of the women women persons he worked
with her name was anita hill said that
he hit on her and said there's a pubic
hair on my coke which was his boring
clumsy way of hitting on her and for
that reason clarence thomas was
perceived to be not qualified to be on
the supreme court scotty beam me up
meanwhile al sharpton has the show on
msnbc and al sharpton is a race hustling
person who became famous by lying about
tawanna brawley he's five million
dollars light in taxes got involved in
the crown heights affair
went to ferguson and said that darren
wilson should be arrested and then of
course darren wilson was exonerated he's
got a show on msnbc donald trump is
fired what world do i live in stephen i
well i don't know i'm not a fan of i
think al sharpton and donald trump
should have a hair war
so it's it's changed it's a changing
world out there
al sharpton okay i want to talk about
that because i was talking with my
producer here
who's younger and he's more apolitical
um gay jared over here and um he's
talked about this al sharpton actually
when compared to my generation of
race-baiters uh like deray and sean king
the people who've made their entire
living online at daily costs or being
funded by soros um al sharpton seems
downright classy have you noticed it
becoming even more aggressive with
people my age
it's funny i was just talking about that
a moment ago on my show uh the
millennials have been now accused of
being almost as racist as
non-millennials which is fascinating
over on msnbc i heard a pun and just now
say that because uh dylan roof
apparently because of his age is i guess
technically a millennial and it
supposedly uh pierces the myth that
millennials are not racist
this guy
is a deviant he couldn't even get a
following he has a racist manifesto
stephen where he complained he can't
even get the clan to join him he wanted
to start a race back and the whole point
is that this guy could not get a
following he was angry he couldn't even
get the klan to follow him he kills nine
people and we're having a discussion
about how much racism there is in
america we didn't have this discussion
about charlie mass and back in 69
madison goals were exactly the same he
wanted to start a race war we wrote him
off as a generate nut he's got a he's
got a swastika tattooed on his forehead
he's a nut and so is his roof guy why
are we having this conversation about
gun control about the confederate flag
ridiculous it is ridiculous i did get a
lot of flack though uh just for saying
hey listen
absolutely people have the right to run
a confederate flag let your freak flag
fly any way you want and amazon and
walmart also have the right to not sell
it if they choose not to that's their
right it's not a first amendment issue
and i said me personally
i'm not going to be pro-confederate flag
and i got so much flack for that people
saying well you know it's about states
rights
this is something actually i would like
your your input on it because maybe it's
a blind spot for me what i said again as
an ignorant white guy said well states
rights don't supersede human rights and
as far as i'm concerned slavery is a
human right issue the federal government
had to abolish slavery am i off on that
no no of course not and if i were in the
legislature in south carolina as i said
repeatedly i would vote against the flag
as well but i would not assume that
everybody who voted against me was a
bigot it's interesting we say that not
every muslim is a terrorist but
apparently everybody who's a proponent
of the confederate flag is a bigot not
fair that's true that's not fair uh it's
not fair but i do think i do think it's
tough when i argue when i say hey i'm
i'm a conservative you know republican
the party of lincoln the party that
freed the slaves and someone's going
to the confederacy i'm like damn it
right
my mom is from huntsville alabama my dad
is from georgia
uh and there are even some black people
who think of the confederate flag as a
symbol of history and a symbol of
southern pride and there are a lot of
white people who feel that way in good
faith so again even though i would not
vote for the flag there are so many
people that resent it so many people
that feel as a symbol of racism and so
many businesses that would not relocate
to my state because of the flag i would
vote against it for all sorts of reasons
but i would not assume that my lawmaker
across the aisle who votes differently
is doing so because of bigotry that's a
good point that sounds incredibly
sensible you know the arguments i i
don't know what you're doing i don't
know what i get lucky every now and then
yeah every now and then i was going to
say every now and then they were wrong
about you on spin city
i remember did you make a cameo on spit
city did you i did make a
i did one also on the d.l higley show
yeah and a show called american dreams i
am an actor this is true you are an
actor did they treat you okay did you
come on and they treated you like a
piece of paper i had i had a cameo
appearance on 24 remember 24 yeah
and one of my buddies uh produces it so
he got me a little cameo thing and when
i was there uh the production assistant
says uh uh so-and-so's friend is here to
do his part i said i'm not so-and-so's
friend i am an actor and she went
so and so his friend the actor is here
well if anyone does any research and
finds out who so-and-so is uh he'll
never produce in hollywood again so
thanks for that larry do they treat you
well on spin city again i was a
youngster so that's where how i was
introduced to you
they really did um they knew that i was
conservative they knew that i probably
had views that would make the ears
explode everybody else uh on the set but
they were very polite to me they also
knew i was there only for a few minutes
and i'd be getting the hell out so they
probably were able to be polite for a
few minutes right yeah i remember
thinking it was a very funny storyline
and uh and i thought you were a good
sport at going in and doing it you know
i've seen rush limbaugh do that and i
remember thinking it was a really
critical error for someone like mitt
romney to say no to snl i'd like to see
more conservatives doing what you're
doing at least being open to i mean
listen you reach across it maybe helps
because you're libertarian and so right
away they go i don't i don't know what
that means can we book them uh we're
gonna bring you back after this break
larry elder larryelder.com
don't leave because he's smarter than me
c